and where are you Jackie exactly so cool
which is in the East Riding of Yorkshire
lots of small villages lots of rural
isolation as well we've been providing
Meals on Wheels service for about twelve
years now so we do a hot meal that's
freshly cooked that morning and then
it's delivered in thermal boxes straight
to the customers so they actually get a
nice meal not a frozen meal or in a
plastic container or anything like that
and Jackie how is the ADT helps you has
it given you some money and what are you
expecting from it because of the panic
buying there was a lot of items that
with that families in particular were
really struggling with we got the
application in and got the fun straight
away so we could buy a powdered milk for
bare bears we could buy sanitary
products for women nappies all sorts so
those those things that were vital but
were being taken off the shelves of the
supermarket so that was great that we
had that really really quickly and could
have those resources there to support
people there's nothing like something
like a crisis to bring you all together
and you know to work cohesively and and
that's really that's really worked well
it's been fantastic
that's good - yeah Jackie I agree with
you I think Britain is at its best
weirdly when we're in a crisis we want
to get there that community spirit and
that community feel comes rushing back
quicker than anything else
absolutely this weekend we're sending
out some bags of happiness so we've had
some of these dragon staff making up
some little bags and they've got scented
candles in they've got some nice
chocolates in Jackie doing a fantastic
job please pass on could I just ask you
to do a high-five for all of the
volunteers in East Riding go high fiver
of course I'll do a virtual high five
that's it look thank you very much thank
you love you sweetie Jackie thank you
bye bye